yeah let me just calibrate the
multiverse hollow projector and we'll be
on our way my friends are from different
earths
here's to rise in IQs and libidos
[Music]
so bad connection hey everybody this is
gonna be my Council of wells episode
there was a crazy number of Easter eggs
there's also some new crossover stuff we
learned that I'll add to the end of the
video
sometimes they're pop-culture references
can feel a little weird but I felt like
they totally worked in the context of
this episode especially Jeff Goldblum
Jurassic Park life finds away there's a
new flash ring giveaway happening all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video on us a winner at the end of this
- so Council of Welles top 10 WTF and
comic-book Easter eggs let's go starting
with number 10 the man that tries to
shoot them is actually the same man that
berry stole the clothes from way back
during season 1 they've said repeatedly
about how they're going back to a very
season one by before season 4 so this is
just another example of them doing a
literal season 1 thing bringing somebody
back for this specific role I mean if
there was an Olympics for bad luck you
didn't just metal pow you Michael Phelps
count to three and imma show you one
yeah
- so number nine they're trying to track
down DeVoe and track down the metahumans
at the same time so they go back to
therapy and even though it's you know
it's a little weird as a little cringy
you do find that they're able to travel
back into the past memories of elongated
man so I'll be interested to see if they
try to use that as a story device or as
a way to try and track down more people
in future episodes because logically if
he was able to remember at least one of
the people on the bus and he remembered
the metahuman from last week that was
the person who was crying the person
that the thinker captured then he can
also probably remember the other people
on the bus given more time in
hypnotherapy
but number eight meet black bison so
obviously this version of the character
is female but in the comics it's a male
character in his power actually comes
from The Talisman so they sort of turned
the comic book II explanation for his
powers into the MacGuffin of the episode
because she's trying to collect all
these artifact pieces and put them
together and bring them back to her
people but I felt like they did a good
job of giving her some motivation in the
episode besides just being ethereal bad
like she actually wants to do the
reverse Indiana Jones thing where her
tribes belongings were pillaged so she's
trying to take them back they even had a
couple of Indiana Jones lions later in
the episode that belongs in a museum so
of all the new metahumans they've
introduced this season so far she's been
one of my more favorite ones at least
her performance I know everybody has
their favorite powers like some powers
just end up being cooler than others but
I thought they did a good job with the
way they expressed hers but number seven
meet the Council of Wells so this is
obviously like one of the big things
that everyone was looking forward to and
I was expecting a few more versions but
I think it just allows them to do more
character work with the versions that
they did aside from just having a
billion of them in the background like a
Rick and Morty episode where you just
see billions of different versions of
them and use that to guess what they
might be alike Council of Rick's
sentences you to the Machine of
unspeakable doom which swaps your
conscious and
conscious minds rendering your fantasies
pointless while everything you've known
becomes impossible to grasp also every
10 seconds it stabs your balls so all of
them are geniuses but Wolfgang Wells is
from earth 12 he just sort of this
nihilist who just craps on everybody's
ideas I don't know if he's supposed to
be a twist on Wolfgang Puck
but earth 47 billionaire lothario Welles
is basically Matthew McConaughey wells
so he was probably my favorite
even though cyborg wells had some of the
better jokes so cyborg wells Wells 2.0
is from earth 22 post-apocalyptic so
they're basically living in like a Mad
Max version of the world so he actually
reminded me of one of the characters
from Judge Dredd when he go into the
wastes he's basically part cyborg
they're cannibals so he felt like the
closest thing that they were going for
because he's like I ate my version of
Cisco so probably one of the funniest
WTF twists that he actually ate his
Cisco and his version of Jesse gouged
his eye out during their annual solstice
Games which sounds like a version of The
Hunger Games then of course we have
number six
Gandalf wells from a non-specific earth
now obviously magic exists in the DC
Universe so you could say there is an
earth where a version of Harrison wells
learn to practice magic and literally
became something like Gandalf the Grey
but I think the idea here is that he
just somebody that they hate any cost
plays and he's just another billionaire
scientists like the rest of them but it
was a great Lord of the Rings reference
especially given that they're actually
developing a Lord of the Rings TV series
right now we have elongated man's suit
so the first version of his suit in the
comics actually looks like this so I
think that's what they're going for with
this very low five version of the suit
he'll probably get something a little
cooler by the end of the season just
because the costume like right there
actually looks like something that you
would wear as cosplay to a convention so
typically the comic book costumes on the
TV shows and it being really expensive
to make so that's why I think they'll
blow past this and give him something
really cool by the end of the season but
just remains to be seen which version of
the costume he winds up getting later
because he worn a couple different ones
in the comics number 5 Frank and beans
Council of Welles
there were just a whole bunch of
pop-culture references sometimes Harry
you're a wizard but they're going to
create a predictive algorithm to track
down the thinker and guess what his
future next move might be using
probability so that's kind of the same
thing that the thinker is doing at the
beginning of the episode - like when you
see all those equations he's using math
to predict future outcomes like he says
in every iteration of this argument I
win so I do like the way they're weaving
practical science into the way he uses
his powers like it's not some ethereal
thing where he just has cosmic sense and
he can know the future he just has a
brain like a supercomputer that can
crunch billions of calculations
necessary to actually try to predict
future outcomes but number four you have
like the big message of the episode that
Barry's trying to teach elongated man
it's always more important to save the
victim to save the innocent person than
it is to catch the bad guy so just
remember that when we get to next week's
episode in the rest of the season with
them trying to chase down the thinker so
Jesse Martin did an interview recently
talking about how Joe West is going to
handle the fight against the thinker and
is it pretty much a game of
one-upsmanship like he's always a couple
of chess moves ahead and it takes a
really dark turn so team Flash and Joe
in particular try to think of ways that
they can get one step ahead and it's
like you know how far do you push that
line what are you willing to do to get
one step ahead of the villain and will
it require you doing something that is
very unheroic like based on the whole
message of this episode it sounds like
that's what's going to happen with Barry
like team flash will have to choose to
save someone over taking down the
villain which you know because of the
twist at the end of the episode with the
thinker sitting in the chair with a full
head of hair just makes me wonder if the
thinker that we've been seeing so far is
more of a mind space ethereal thinker
like we're literally inside some sort of
cyberspace presence or inside his mind
and this is his body so they're like
dual selves to the thinker so he's
running around inside his head wool is
also wheeling around in normal
3-dimensional space on the earth so
think about it that way like maybe
there's a version of the thinker that's
not that bad of a person so number three
was the Battle of the Museum
they did a pretty good job creative use
of powers like you see Ralph wrap
himself around the dinosaurs mouth you
get that awesome Jeff Goldblum Jurassic
Park reference and Barrie finds a
creative way of using black Bisons
desires against her like she's all about
preserving the things that are precious
to her people
so he threatens that think about that
when it comes to them fighting the
thinker will Barry find out about
something that's precious to the thinker
and try to dangle that in front of him
in order to try and one-up him number
two elongated man learns his lesson goat
you know goes to see the girl was a very
touching scene but also gives the
artifacts reverse Indiana jones-style
back to the Sioux people which was the
whole thing that black bison was trying
to do so I like the way they're playing
in that morally gray space where heroes
sometimes have to go outside the law and
do the wrong thing in order to do the
right thing so I'm expecting that to be
part of Barry's journey this season to
like usually he knows what the right
thing to do is but when he's fighting
the thinker when Joe's fighting the
thinker they might get a little dark so
I think people will be happy with the
direction that's taking but you know
number one obviously is them going up to
the thinker's doorstep you see the
mechanic who actually looks like a
normal housewife and you see the thinker
with a full head of hair wheeling around
so one Barry is probably triggered and
has a flashback to harrison wells in the
wheelchair during season one oh my god
another villain in a wheelchair and very
clearly he looks much better than the
thinker that we've been seeing in this
weird space here so I think the
interesting thing or maybe the big twist
that we'll learn is that this you know
blue light space here isn't actually in
the real world maybe it's some sort of
mind space or some sort of cyberspace
and that explains like when he was
playing chess a couple of episodes ago
why it looks super advanced and
holographic because the whole space
might be something that he's dreamt up
in his mind but next week's episode is
all about the thinker it's called
therefore I am as in I think therefore I
am cogito ergo soon which I'm probably
mispronouncing but also some stray
observations there are a couple Easter
eggs that I haven't mentioned yet the
funniest one was actually at the
beginning of the episode where Caitlin
talks about how killer frost went to
Burning Man
because that just sounds really silly
but then you also think about Ronnie
like she went to Burning Man even though
that Burning Man has been dead for a
while so just a very cool meta joke
talking about firestorm and the
real-life Burning Man but aside from a
straight terminator reference and Free
Willy Wells there weren't that many
other pop-culture references that I
spotted if you did see any that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments so what will
happen nexuses i'll post my trailer
video for next week's episode
but tomorrow night the embargo is up for
Justice League so I'll post my review
video that'll be a little bit later in
the evening though so we'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner
Zozo please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
the new four-way crossover trailer and
you can click here for my non-spoilery
Justice League reaction thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight